では よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマは早速始まります
自己ベストを生きるということで
一応どういう意味かということは
まあそれなりにご存知だと思います
その テーマについて  いくつかの仏教の考え方を紹介したいと思います
一番最初にお釈迦様がもういわゆる仏典からなんですけど
お釈迦様の言葉からいくつか勉強してみましょう
アチャリットワブラフマチャリアン アラッダヨッバネーダナン ジッナコンチャーワジャーヤンティ キーナマッチェーワパッレレ
あんまりいい加減な日本訳なんですけど
だから直訳で見ていくと
アチャリットワブラフマチャリアンまあ修行なんかは全くしないということなんですね
ブラフマチャリアっていうのは
まあ道徳的な清らかな
ただ欲に溺れて生活するんじゃなくて
まあ立派な人間として道徳的な生き方をすることで
特にそれはインドの世界の習慣でもありますから
あとで説明いたします
アラッダヨッバネーダナン
ヨッバネーっていうのは
若い時はダナンっていうのは富
財産なんですね アラッダ
それも獲得する 収入を得ることもしないで
まあ道徳的な真面な真面目な人生も送ることもなくて
若い時は仕事をして収入を得ることもしない人はね
ジンナコンチャーっていうのはもう老い溺れこぼれた白鷺なんですね
ジャーヤンティっていうのは
なんか下向いていて なんかもうしている状態なんですね
キーナキーナ マッチャっていうのは魚のこと
キーナっていうのはないという
魚がいないパッレレ沼
こう追いこぼれた白鷺だから飛べないんですね
それで沼 沼にいることはいるんだけど
沼に魚もいないんです
かわいそうなんですよ
だからお釈迦様はすごく
なんかすごく惨めやと言ってるんですよ
結局は 道徳的な修行をして立派な人間人格者になることもないし
あるいはただごく普通に仕事をして豊かになって
俗世間の人生でも成功したことはない人のこと
すごく惨めで まあということを言ってるんですね
いわゆる人生に負けた人ですね
それは仏教はあまりありがたいことやと思ってないんです
で また続けてもう一つ偈があるんです
アチャリットワブラフマチャリアン アラッダヨッバネーダナン センティチャーチャーパーティキーナーワ プラーナーニ アノットゥナン
それも一つのお釈迦様の話で
アチャリットワブラフマチャリアン アラッダヨッバネーダナン
センティチャーパーティーキーナーワ プラーナーニ アノットゥナン
で  1 1 行目は同じですね
修行することもなく また若い時
元気な時 収入を得ることもなくいる馬鹿者はね
センティチャーパーティーキーナーワ
放たれた矢のごとく 地面に落ちて
これ何でしたっけ？愚痴る
愚痴る矢のように 過去を思い悩むんだと
これすごい惨めなんですね
だから戦う時は弓から矢
矢を撃つんだけど 的に当たってないんです
敵に当たってないんです
敵に当たってない そこら辺どこかに落ちるでしょうね
そのまま朽ちていくんです
矢として何の責任も果たしてないんです
ただ無駄ということで
だから戦争でいっぱい矢を放っても
的に当たらなかった矢は全部もう敵にちゃんと当たらなかったのは全部無駄でしょうね
それで無駄な人生だと
それで人間っていうのは
やるべきことはやらない
やるべき時 やるべきことをやらないで
後で追い込まれたところで
あれやっておけばよかった
これやっておけばよかったとかね
あれやこれやと言ってるだけで
だからこうすればよかったと過去を悩む人は人生失敗しているんですよ
もし我々も何かたまたまあれやっておけばよかったなとかね
ああいうことをしておいた方がよかったなとかね
まあ出かける前に鍵をかけた方がよかったなとか
今更悩んだってもう失敗でしょ
だからこの過去形でやっておけばよかったというね
このコンディショナルセンテンスというかね
これを使うんだったらね
もう人生はもうダメに決まってるんです
だから仏教ではこの誰と付き合えばいいかと
この友人関係すごく大事にしますよ
大体人と喋ったらすぐわかりますよ
あ そうですね あれやっておけばよかったなとかね
私は人間関係それでは切るんで
その人とはもう付き合うと私の時間の無駄になるんだと
そうだなとかね なんだろうかなとかね
言うともう徹底した無知な人で
もう付き合うとものすごいストレス溜まるんです
だからそういう言葉でわかるんですよ
だから 特に自分が楽しく生きていければ
かなりいい仲間を作らないと
仲間っていうのは夢の話ばっかりする人だったら
もう犬を買った方がいいんです
猫とかね 結構頭いいんですよ
猫とかね だから人間っていうのはああすればよかった
こうすればよかったとかね
もっと勉強しておけばよかったとかね
そう言われると ああ そうですね
それはよかったですね
はい ではさようならと
ということをしなくちゃいけないんです
そういう人々は 自分が失敗したら勝手に失敗してね
勝手に苦しむのはいいんだけど
他の人々を道連れにするんですよ
だから友達がなくて その人は一人で悩んだってのは知ったもんじゃないんでしょうに
こちらのせいじゃないでしょうに
この慈悲っていうのは
もうすごくもう誤解して欲しくないんです
自分が破壊しつつ 人に教えにするということは
もう智慧のある人がやることじゃないんです
だから まあ若い時は厳しく言うんだけど
で 厳しく言って育てようとする
それでもわがままでいい加減で
自分がもう何もしないで
人生はダメになったところで
誰かに引っかかってもしゃべる
しゃべるしゃべる それで人のまで迷惑かける
だからくだらない話についていかなくちゃいけないんだからね
そういうことだから 大体このまあ
人生失敗している人っていうのはよく簡単にわかります
この 2つのお釈迦様の言葉で
そういう人々は自分で考えるしかないんです
そちらのブッダのアドバイスがありますけど
今日は入れてないんですけど
一応入れてないんですけど
紹介します アッターナンウェピアピアンジャンニャラッケイアナンスラッヒタンティンナマンニャタランヤーマンパティジャッゲイエパンディト
あなたは自分のことを好きやと思うならば
自己を守りなさいよと
人生にはこのピリオドメスあります
若い時 中 年の時 老人の時とかね
それいつ一つだけでもしっかりと育ててみなさいと
若い時失敗したら 中年の時はしっかりした人間になる
そうすると老年になってもしっかりした人間なんですね
中年の時でもバカでいたならば
まあ老人の時でもしっかり頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
それは自分のことは好きであるならばなんですよ
だからそういうこの人生失敗する人々は
結局自分自身のことも好きじゃないんです
というか まあ無知もいいところです
本当は好きなんですよ
好きなのに自己破壊の過程方法を選んでしまうんです
それだったら勝手にしなさいという答え正しいんですよ
それなのに また社会も道連れにしようかなと
家族も道連れにしようかなと
お母さんも道連れにしようかなとかね
で 道連れにしようとするんです
特にお母さんたちは大変ですよ
だらしない子供が生まれてきたら
自分たちの人生までダメになっちゃうんです
どうしようもないでしょう
小さい時から育てなくちゃいけないし
それで母親も母親で一人だけさせないし
それで本来性格的にだらしないんだったら
まあ二人とも同じ運命になっちゃうんです
だからこの厳しいんですよ
生きるっていうことは
甘く見るんじゃないんです
何一つもこの世の中でね
もうただのものっていうのはないでしょうに
何でもかんでもすごい厳しいんです
この厳しい世界で生き抜くために
生き残るためには 必要なのはもう理解能力なんですよ
物事の判断なんですね
しっかり自分のことを判断して行動するんですよ
だから行動する上では
ちょこっと勇気っていうものはね
やってみようと だからその2つ揃っていればね
理解能力と行動力ですね
一応行き場がわからないんだけど
やってみましょうということで
で 判断が正しければ 行き場ではなくて
ちゃんと行きますよ うまくいきます
だから そういう勇気のある人間が
ブッダは称賛しているんです
他の人々はただまあいないことにしているんです
で ブッダにしたって短い時間でしたから
もう生ゴミばっかり預けて預かってもうどうにもならないんだからね
だから選んで選んで すごい能力のある
知識のある 勇気のある
頑張る人々を選んで選んで説法するんです
どんな距離でも歩くんです
時々ちっちゃな子供に会うために
長い距離をもう何日もかけて歩くんです
あるいはその子供に説法して帰るんです
村人はもう知らんふり
村人のこと 村人はせっかくお布施も作ってお布施しているのに
それをいただいて子供に説法して帰るんです
なぜかというと その子供たちは頭が良くて理解する
悟り開ける 大人は全然そういう見込みがなかったら
まあほとんど相手にしないというか
まあもう真剣にかかろうとはしない
自分の大事な時間はあまり使わない
ブッダの時間を使ったっていうのは
必ず悟り人に対してはご自分の時間を使っていたんです
そういうことだから 最初からもう厳しいということだけ覚えておいてください
もう宗教みたいな甘い話はないんです
で 今の 2つのお釈迦様の言葉で解説なんですけど
自己ベストを尽くし 生きることは釈尊に評価されています
だから仏教の世界っていうのは
本当に自己ベストを尽くすことなんですね
だからで 仏教徒はみんなそうやっているのかというと
そうじゃないんです だから仏教の世界っていうのは
随分だらしなくて いい加減でまとめがなくて
わがままでっていうことはもう歴史上事実としてあるんです
しかし ブッダはそういう世界
を作ったわけじゃないんです
だから仏教徒だと自慢げに言いながら
ブッダに嫌われることを選んでやるっていうことは
まあ仏教史上もうよくあったことで
今もそういうことで 何をやっているのかというと
仏教徒ならもうとんでもないことばっかりやっていることもあります
それをなぜか仏教は別に人を管理したりとかね
まあ教会みたいにね まあ厳しくやらないんだから
その自由を悪用しているんです
それから この 2つの偈で我々何がわかるのかというと
生きる目的があるんですね
まあ私は別に 人生に生きることに意味があるのは何の意味もないんですけど
意味がなくても何か目的を作って
それを目指して努力することは悪くないんです
なんで人が生きているのかというと
死んでないんだからなんですよ
それしか答えがまるっきりないんです
まあ死んでないんだから生きてるんだといえば
ものすごくもうなんか虚しいでしょうね
ただ何か食べて 寝て起きて
また食べて で それでそうして死ぬってぐらいは意味がないんだからこそ
何か目的を作るんですよ
作って それを目指して頑張ってみる
で 仏教 だから仏教的には目的 2つなんです
一番一番大事な目的は
修行して清らかな超越した心を育すことなんです
あの偈でアチャリットはブラフマチャリアンタってのはそういうことなんです
だから悟りを開く 前紹介した偈で 1番目にあの 1 行目の 1 番目セクションはアチャリットはブラフマチャリア
ブラフマチャリアっていうのは出家して修行することなんです
まあはっきり言えば 人間に生まれたならば
まあ出家して修行した方が生まれてきた目的に達したことになるんです
他何やっても無駄なんですよ
残らない結果は いくら科学者になって
もうものすごい精密な武器開発しましたとかね
もうもうこれからまあ 40年でも使える武器を作ったとかね
そんなの何やっても 自然は全部丸ごと破壊しましたぞとかね
あらゆる機械を作って
そういうものは死ぬ時は持っていかれるものじゃないんです
だからこのまあ 科学者の考え方も科学的という言葉を使っていますから
これ本当に世の中での科学的っていうのはいかに無知的やっていうことなんです
それで今日はそういう
あのテレビで  NHK でなんとか番組を見ていたんです
で どこかの湖なんですけど
この 外来というか なんとか魚がね
そちらにも捨てられちゃって
何魚でした？ブルーギルですね
で 全部自然を破壊しているんだと
だから昆虫は食べるわ
もう何でもかんでも食べてしまうっていうこと
それで繁殖すると それで東京大学のその自然関係の教授がすごい厳密に調べてきて
ましてこの魚も何十万
何万匹みたいなものは
もうものすごい数を減らすようにしたんだと
卵を処分したり もうもう毎年たくさん魚を取って捨てたりとかね
で 数を減ったんです  1900匹ぐらいに
次に沼に行ってみたら
沼は自然に戻ってるんじゃなくて
何か特別なもう雑草がサーッと出てきて
他の生命に誰にも生きることができなくなっているんです
それは後で発見するんですね
それからそれがもう何とかしようかなと思ったらと
まあそれは取り出しちゃうとまた自然破壊になるんだから
周りのあの 湖の周りにある植物やら葉っぱやら草やら
全部もう切って切って処分するという
これ大作業なんです それでも
湖の大きさと周りの環境から見れば
もうそう簡単に結果は出てこないんだと
年ぐらいにはなるんだと
何か思い浮かんだことをやるだけの話なんですよ
そこで この外来の動植物によって自然は破壊したんだという人間の主観なんですよ
それもそれで元に戻す
戻すそうと思うことは
私は科学的ですか？と私が聞きたいんですよ
あの先生はもう面白く
あれはだいたい教頭の先生たちで
京都大学の先生たちがやってるんですけど
なんか不思議に東京大学の教授もそういう自然を守るために手を出しているっていうことは面白かったんですけど
で 名前だけで立場あるんだからね
何もしないんです だから
まあでも立派な方でね
だから本人の研究分野は素晴らしいことかもしれませんだけど
まあごく一般的に考えれば
元に戻すってどういうことですかね
何か元に戻せる なんで科学者にそれはわからないんですかね
何か元に戻せるっていうことはできないんですよ
それ自体ヘタクソなんですよ
ある自然環境が壊れたっていうことは
それには生存できなかったっていうことなんです
そうすると 無理やり環境を作ってあげて残してもらうっていうことは不自然でしょう
そのためにどれぐらいの他の生命は犠牲にならなくちゃいけないんですかね
だからこのまあ かわいそうなかわいそうとは感じますけど
それは人間の主観で もう
何か動物が消えてしまったとか
かわいそうだなとかね
思うのはかわいそうでしょうかね
別にわかりませんだけど
私は元に戻そうっていうことはありえないと思いますよ
それ科学的な思考じゃないと思いますけど
だから何をしようとも
こういうすごい因果法則をちゃんと考えて
物事は確実に変化していくんだぞということを考えて
頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
頑張らなくたってもいいんだけど
まあ人間頑張るということは
例えば物事は変化するんだぞというと
この変化の中で自分がどうやって生き続けるのかということを考えるんですよ
それは科学的じゃないんです
生き続けるということは成り立たないんです
自分も変化していくんだから
だから仏教はそういう思考はもういい加減うんざりっていうことでやめてもらって
もっと大事なことに挑戦する
心育てるっていうこと
だから人間に生まれてならば
作るべき目的は  第1というか
唯一の目的は修行すること
で 心をしっかり育てること
心の無知を破ること 知恵を開発すること
解脱することなんだ そうなると
まあ世界は変わろうが変わらなかろうが
何の関係もなく 自分が解脱しているんです
それで人に教えるならば
その解脱の道を教える
人に協力するならば 解脱をするために協力してあげる
それを唯一の人助けなんです
ご飯あげても すごい一時的なんです
パキスタンの地震の被害者たちに毛布を送っても
まあそれすごい一時的なもので
それでパキスタン人の生きる問題は解決したことには全くならないんです
また地震が起きたらどうしましょうかと
みんなに家を作ってあげたっても
また地面が揺れちゃうともう全部壊れますから
だからこのやっぱり残るもの
無常の世界で唯一残っていくものっていうのは
心清らかにしたことなんです
悟ったことなんですから
仏教では生きる時の第 1 どうして修行することを考えてるんです
しかし これができる人っていうのはものすごい稀で少ないんです
決める人もいるんですけど
気持ちは怪しいんです
別に本当に真理知りたい
解脱したいっていう気持ちじゃないんです
2番目 あるいは俗世間的に見て成功者だと言える生き方をする
1はできないんだったら 2番目やってくださいと
人間としてしっかり生きてみなさいよ
成功者になりなさいよと
こんなのは単純だよっていうのはブッダの立場なんです
それは無知な人に選んであげている道だからね
智慧のある人は出家して解脱するんです
だから 2番目の目的は
その他大勢の無知な人々に言ってることで
成功者になりなさい これどれほど無知かというと
これもすごい大変なことやと思うんだからね
人生成功者になるっていうことは
それだったらもうどう話にならない
あまりにも単純でしょうに
おもちゃ遊びみたいな単純なことなんですよ
もう人生もう成功するっていうこと
なんでそれもできなくて失敗するのかと
まあ一応こういう 2つの目的がございます
その目的もまあ一応まあみんなに興味あるのは 2番目ですからね
今日の話はだいたい 2番目のテーマになります
また お釈迦様 経典から引用します
この場合はちょこっとしたこのエピソードが入ってしまって
このこのある経典を選んだんですけど
選んだ瞬間からもう大変なことになったんです
この経典の訳は誰にもできないんです
注釈書を読んでみたら
もう注釈書を書いた方
ブッダゴーサ長老にももう訳できなくて
なんとかなんとかなんとかゴチャゴチャゴチャしているんです
それで昨日夜 事務長事務所の方に行って
このすごい立派に研究して現代英訳しているんだからね
あるアメリカ人のお坊さんがスリランカに住んでいるお坊さんですけど
シンハラ語も知っていて
いろんな言語を知っていて
資格は全部揃ってるんです
翻訳する場合は 読んでみたらもっとおかしい
そのセクション その人はあらゆるところを参考しているんです
参考しても 自分でこれではないかという訳はしていますけど
私はこれも完全にペケではないかなと思ったんです
どうしようかと これっていうのは大変なことになりました
それでエピソードは この大釈典っていうのは
大体この仏教ではこの在家信者さんを象徴するために
いろんなもう王様が出るわ
在家の人々でいろいろな役柄あるんです
たまたま神様も現れるんですね
神様とは帝釈天という神様なんですけど
この天界の王様なんですね
管理者なんですね たくさん名前がありまして
お釈迦様とは随分仲良しで
すごいしっかりした人格者なんです
それで彼のところにスシーマという名前の神がいたんです
これ 英訳で若手の神と書いてますけど
神には若い年寄りはないんですけど
それも英訳したお坊さんのなんか誤解やと思いますけど
まあ一応まあなんとなく若手と言った方がかっこいいんだから
私はその単語を使ったんですけど
神には若い老人ということはないんです
それでアシュラという神々にスラと言うんです
で 神々と攻撃闘って攻撃する同じランクの人々をそれは阿修羅と言うんですね
で まあこの輪廻六道の場合は六道といえば入りますけど
五道ですけど 阿修羅という次元がないんです
仏典では だからまあ同じところで生活していた神々だと思います
でも仲が悪い おそらく性格は違う
もう神というスラという人々は
いくらかすごい品格よく
道徳を守って 落ち着いておとなしくいると
阿修羅はそうじゃなくて
かなり派手で ちょこっと乱暴で
もうすごい楽しく生きているわと思います
道徳とか行儀よくとか
そんなものは何もないと
まあクラシック音楽をね
オーケストラ聴く場所と
もうどこかの飲み屋さんでロック音楽を聴いて踊ってる場合
そういう感じなんですよ
だからどこかのフィルハーモニーオーケストラなんかでは
みんなしっかりした服を着て
じーっと座っていて 音楽を聴いて帰る
ちゃんと並んでポップ音楽なんかやっているところはまるっきり正反対で
もうおとなしいところじゃなくて
もう服着ているところじゃなくて
どんどん服も脱ぐんですよ
時々踏まれて死んだりもするんです
歌ってる人も聞いてる人も
音楽も大体半分ぐらい行ってると
ほとんど服も着ていない状態で
まあ結局どちらも楽しいというか
楽しいんですけどね だから楽しみ方は2種類と
同じ音楽を聴いてもそんな感じで
スラと阿修羅という同じ次元の神々がいて
まあそういう性格は違うと私は思いますけど
それでも攻撃したんですよ
阿修羅たちが 神々を これえらい邪魔
迷惑なんですね 落ち着いていられないんです
そこでスシーマという神に
あなたはね それは何とかしてくださいと
帝釈天が頼んだんです
それでその人は何やったかというと
全然何もしないで怠けていたんです
だから神にいろんなものを頼むんじゃないんですよ
やってくれないんですよ
これ帝釈天王様が頼んだでしょうに
王様方が直々仕事を頼んだのに
何もやってない 自分の世界でぼーっとしているんです
それでも阿修羅たちがかなりもう調子に乗って攻撃していて
これはうるさい 我慢できない
もう一度頼んだんです
何もやらなかった また言ったんです 3
回も 3回も命令したんですけど
彼は怠けたんです 何もしなかったんです
それで普通だったら王様だからね
打ち首にしますけどね
それではもう神様 帝釈天
神様だからそれはしないし
まだ帝釈天だからすごい理想的な
仏教から見れば そういう怠けていて
もう話は聞かない人に対してでも
どんな態度を取るのかというと
これから勉強できますよ
会社だったらすぐクビなんですけど
帝釈天はスシーマ神をこのように叱ったんです
で 叱ったということは私が入れたんですけど
翻訳した人々はこれ叱ったかないかどうか分からなくなっているんです
私は常識的に これはまあ叱ったことなんですけど
うまくいかなかっただけ
それで帝釈天は言うんです
アヌッタハンアワーヤマン Суカンヤトラディガッチャティスシーマタッタガッチャヒーマンチャタッテウェパーパヤー
この翻訳者がこの言語に引っかかってますね
また これは真剣に考えていないんです
私は専門家ではないんだから出しゃばったことは言いませんだけど
こういうところの問題だと思いますけど
アヌッタハンというのはもう踏ん張ることなんですよ
踏ん張りないこと これは否定形だからね
ウッタ ウッタハ ここからは踏ん張っちゃう
もう頑張ってみるという
アヌッタンというのは
それを踏ん張ること 頑張ること何もない
アワーヤーマンというのはもうもう負けず嫌いで
もうとにかくとにかく
それでもそれでもそれでもやってみるという
いわゆる引き続く もうやりやり続くことなんです
ウッタハンというのはもう活発的で
もう何といいますか じゃあやろうではないかと
やろうではないか 例えば山を登ろうとする
それで準備して じゃあ登ろうというのはウッタハナ
ウッタハナなんですよ
でも元気で登る人なんか
途中で足が痛くて もう空気が薄くなっちゃって
もうダメでしょ もう引き上げたくなるんですよ
それででも引き上げないで
まあとにかくやろうと頂上まで行くという
だから精進と言えば 2種類なんです
まず行動を起こす勇気
それから何といいますか
続く勇気なんです その 2つはこちらで言ってます
アヌッタンアワーヤーマン
もう頑張ることもしないし
それから引き続けて精進することもないし
そういう状態で いわゆる何もしないでバカみたくいて
スカンヤットラアジガッチャティ
スカンというのは幸福ですね
何か幸福を得られると思うならば
やったらアジガッチャティ
そういう幸福の境地あるならば
スシーマ スシーマくんパッタガッチャーリ
あんたそちらに行きなさい
これえらい叱りなんですよ
あのね スシーマ 何も努力しないで
何も踏ん張ることをしないで
ただボケーとして最高な幸福になるということがあったら
君がそちらに行きなさいと
すごい叱りなんですよ
だから仕事もしないで
勉強もしないで もう何もしないで
ご飯食ってテレビだけ見ていることで
あなたはすごい豊かな人間になるならば
そういう豊かさはどうぞご自由にやってくださいという意味なんです
そういうふうに言われると
本当にもうやる気が出てくるんです
皆様の叱り方はもうちょっと違います
とにかくダメにしてやるぞと叱るんです
人は子供で勉強していないで遊んでいると
よかったよかったと もっと遊びなさいよ
と言った方が効くんですよ
あんた何するのか なんで遊びばっかりで勉強しなさいよと
ダメになるんだよと言っちゃうと
あんたに関係ないんだよ
いう態度を取るんです
それは子供は知らないんですよ
だって本来みんな自由だから
そこ衝動が湧いてきますよ
私は将来どうなってもあんたに関係ないでしょ？という態度でやらないんですよ
だからどうぞどうぞ そのままでいいんだよというふうに自由を与えたところで
すごい怖くなるんです
それで帝釈天は仏教的に正しい叱り方で叱ったんです
いわゆるもう徹底的な怠け者が得られるすごい幸福の境地っていうものがあるんだったら
どうぞそちらに行ってくださいと
資格あるんだから もう徹底的に怠けたんだから
このスシの神は そこでこの注釈書のところでも
仏教伝統で おそらく全ての人々は学者がそこら辺間違っていると思いますけど
ブッダがちょっと理解できなかったところだから
当然こういうところなんで
マンチャっていうのはこのどう訳するのかということで
それでパーパヤっていうのは
単純なパーリ語だったら
私も連れて行きなさいという意味なんです
単純な意味では いわゆる連れて行くっていう意味であって
だから英訳では帝釈天
そういうところに私も連れてきて行きなさいよというふうな英訳なんです
ちょっとそうすると理屈は成り立たないんですね
だから微妙な別の今マンチャっていうのは
consider よせよという意味で
例えばそのようにパーペyou have to become just as it is という意味でなければいけません
いわゆるあなたはそういう状態になってくださいと
そういう状態になることは考えておきなさいという訳でなければいけないんです
でも それでも簡単じゃないんです
次の次の偈になってくると
微妙に仏教の真理にこれ変えていくんだから
この言葉の英語でパンという同じ言葉で 2つの意味を言うというね
英語でそれはパンと言うんですね
パン そういうことを結構パーリ語でやりますから
そういうところで引っかかるんで
とにかく皆様にはそんな専門的なことは関係ないので
大釈天が何言うのかというと
怠け者が得られる幸福があるならば
どうぞご自由にそれになってくださいという意味なんです
逆に何言うのかというと
怠け者は不幸になるに決まってるんだよと
それは言わないんです
そう言うと なんかあまりもしつこいんですよ
なんかおせっかいなんですね
だから微妙にこの自由の立場を保ちながら
そういう境地あるかないか本人調べればよろしいし
あったらどうぞ自由に行ってくださいと
自由だからね という意味になるんです
そこでこの神様も負けません
厳しく叱られたのに アラス
ワッツアヌッタータナチャキッチャーニカーレ
アラスワッサっていうのはもう怠け者に
アヌッタータっていうのは精進努力しない人に
ナチャキッチャンカーレナチャキッチャーニカーレ
あらゆる作業ですね 仕事ですね
そういうものは何もしない
怠けていて 頑張ることもしないで
何もやらない サッバカーマサミダスト
しかし サッバカーマっていうのは自分を期待するもの
自分の希望 希望はすべて成就する
もう徹底的に怠けて何もやらない人なのに
自分の希望だけはすべて成就すると
そういう境地はタンメーサッカワランディサ
この境地がワラン 素晴らしいと
その地さっていうのは境地ですよ
ああいう境地なんだったら
私はすごく好きな好きですよと
もう怠けの象徴なんです
しかし 英訳する人々も
注釈書でもこのセクションはまた引っかかっているんです
そこでワランディサワランっていうのは
この私にそのご褒美を与えてくださいというふうに書いているんです
そうするとまた意味がわからなくなります
ワランというのは 2つの意味があります
例えば神様 王様が じゃああなたに何かあなたの希望を 3つ叶えるようにしてあげましょうとかね
まあいろいろ物語あるでしょ
もう誰が神様が では 3つ希望を叶えてあげますよとかね
そういうふうに何かチャンスを与えることがワランというんですよ
しかし それだけじゃない意味は
ワランというのはグッドエクセレントという意味もあります
ディサっていうのは地方という意味もありますし
私はそういうふうに訳したんです
怠けて精進もしないで何もしないのに
一切の希望が叶うところがあるならば
帝釈天 私はその境地が好きですと
だから帝釈天も結構困ったでしょう
このアホやと思ったでしょうね
せっかく叱っているのに
そういう境地が好きだと
それなんだ あべこべの答えでしょう
だから私はものすごいわかりやすい訳したんですよ
もうずっと学者の伝統とはまるっきり逆らって
この訳は誰もやってないんです
やれないんですよ まあいろいろ決まりあるんだから
しかし 私は自分がつけた訳だから一番いいと思ってるしね
だって悪い訳はしないでしょうに
で 結構考えて考えて こんな訳ではないかなと
それでもなんかおかしいでしょうしね
この二人は それ あんまりおかしくないんです
これ じわじわと仏教の涅槃の境地に話を持っていこうという企みなんです
はい 次に行きます おかなおこないがないところとは
まあ続けます 同じ経典が
ヤッターラソアヌッタータアッチャンタンすか
メーデティスシームタットガッチャヒーマンチャタッテーヴァパタヤ
ちょっと打ち間違いです
やったあるそう アラソっていうのは怠け者
やったっていうのは怠け者にふさわしいっていうことです
で 私はそれは焦ることなくと訳したんです
大体怠けない人っていうのは結構焦るでしょう
怠けてる人は焦れませんね
アヌッタータっていうのは
まあ踏ん張って頑張ること
精進することをね 励むこともなく
焦ることもなく アッチャンタンすか
メーデティ極端な いわゆる究極な極端という
これも間違ってますけど
究極なね 究極なすく幸福を獲得するならば
そこである究極な幸福な境地があります
そこではもう怠けるか怠けないかという感が関係ない
関係ないんだから 私は焦ることはないという訳にしたんです
で 励むことも関係ないんです
そこで帝釈天言うんですよ
スシマよ スシマ君 その境に至るようにするが良い
じゃあ君はまあそういう境地に行くようにしてくださいと
この時点ででも帝釈天はなんか叱ってる可能性あります
次の偈でスシマ神は別なことを言うんです
スシーマ神はちょこっとしたアドバイスするんですよ
このもう怠けたら悪いね
アカンムナーデーヴァセッタ
サッカヴィンデーモヤンスカン
アソーカンアヌパーヤーサン
タンメーサッカワランディサン
ここからすっごい微妙に難しくなって
微妙じゃない もうずっとこの芸はもうかなりものすごいややこしい経典なんです
アカンムナーっていうのはカンマという言葉知ってますね
カンマ 業 それから行為もカンマという業ですね
働くことをですね 行為することですね
それから業ですね 業がないところ
デーヴァセッタっていうのは神々の偉い人っていう意味なんですね
いわゆる帝釈天のことなんですね
で サッカっていうのは大将線の名前
偉大なる神よ 行い 業がなく
得られるその憂い悲しみがない幸福は
やはりこちら ヴィンデーモヤンスカン
あの幸福を楽しみましょうと
アソーカンというのは憂いがない
アヌパーサーヤンというのは心であれこれと悩むことはない
だから 憂い悲しみがない幸福な境地があるならば
私はそこが好きよと その幸福の境地では何もやることはないんだと
全ての行為 行い 業が消えているんだということを言われちゃったんですね
そうすると帝釈天がなんか考えちゃったんで
この人はただのバカじゃないんだと
ただの怠け者じゃないんだけど
何かすごいことを言ってるんだと
この怠けを謳ってるんじゃないんだと思って
次の経典は入れてないんですけど
帝釈天答えるんですよ
君が言う境地っていうのは涅槃でしょうと
これ俗世間と関係ないんだと
だから君が期待しているのは
この一切の行為を終了したところで獲得する
憂い悲しみは何一つもない不死なる境地で涅槃でしょうと
どうか頑張ってくださいと
それで 私の主観的な考え方なんですと
おそらくスシーマさんはね
この政治的にあんた方はいい加減にしなさいとかね
うるさくするなよとかね
もうあすらたちに対して攻撃をかけたり
警察連れて行って この暴動を抑えたりとかね
そんなくだらんことをやりたくない
なんだ こんなことやらなくちゃあかんかと
いくら帝釈天頼まれてもね
といって もしかするとスシーマ神はもっと違うこと
生命たるものは心の穏やかさを目指すべきではないかと思っていた可能性はあります
涅槃では精進なしと ですから涅槃であると
サチェアッティアカンメーナコーチクイッチネジーバティ
ニッバーナッサイソーマッゴースシーマタッタガッチャーヒマンチャタッテーヴァパーパヤ
それで帝釈天の答えはサチェアッティ
もしあるならば アカンメーナ
行いをしないことで コーチクイッチネジーバティ
誰もどこも生きて生きることはしない場所
だから誰かが言うということも
涅槃の場合は言えないんです
涅槃はどこにあるのかということも成り立たないんです
これは難しいんで その定義はすごい難しい
そういう境地はニッバーナッサイソーマッゴー
それは涅槃であると その道は
だったらスシーマスシーマくん
タッタガッチャーヒ そちらに行きなさいよと
マンチェタッテーヴァパーパヤ
そちらに導かれるようにと計らいなさいよということで
帝釈天は叱る 叱って始めたんですけど
アドバイスで終わっちゃったんです
だからそこは悪いことをした人に対してでも
仏教的にはどんな態度するのかっていうとね
相手をバカにしないんですよ
相手の理解 考え方に合わせてしっかりと話し合うということを聞いたんです
だからスシーマ神のある考え方あったんです
こんなややこしい俗世間のことには関わり持ちたくないと
うるさい 煩わしいんだと
そういうことは 頑張って頑張って幸福になっても
それは煩わしい幸福であると
だから頑張ることも 向上することも
行うことも何もない 穏やかな憂い
悲しみのない境地なら
それが幸福ではないかなと思っていたんですよ
だから大釈尊も叱りたかったんですけど
結局は叱れなくなって終わって
終わりで終わったんです
もう一つ偈がありますけどね
そこでお釈迦様の言葉で経典は終わるんです
帝釈天さえも精進することを称賛するのだという釈尊の言葉で
このお経は終わる 全部丸ごと経一つは偈一つ抜けてるんです
で もう取り出しちゃったんですけど
全部丸ごと経典一つなんです
そこで最後にお釈迦様は
この帝釈天と須磨さんの対話はこうであったと言って
それはお釈迦様が言うんだから
ブッダの言葉になるんです
だからお釈迦様が否定するんだったら
使わない 引用しないんです
ダメだったら言ったことは
それでお釈迦様が言うのは
あの帝釈天は精進することは努力することはものすごく称賛するんだよと
そこであんた方は恵まれているんだよと比丘たちに言うんですよ
だって 真理を発見した悟り
小学者がいて この小学者の教えがあって
その教えに従って努力することをあなた方にできるんだから
恵まれているんだよと
頑張りなさいよと 怠けるなよということで
経典は終了するんです
はい で その経典から解説ありましたっけ？あります
で 何を理解するのかというと
人は涅槃の境地を体験しない限り
精進努力は欠かせないものです
この世の中で水一杯飲む時でも
何か精進しないと飲めないんです
好き勝手に水が喉を通っちゃうとかなり苦しいんですよ
あの 何でしたか トラキアと気管支やりますね
その中に入るんだから
食道ではなくて 呼吸器官に入っちゃうと
もうひどい目に遭うでしょうに
だからまあただ水一杯飲むことさえも
それなりの努力は必要なんです
で それで涅槃を体験しない限りは
もう努力しなくちゃいけない
涅槃もただで得るものではないんです
しかし この涅槃という境地も
普通の人よりはるかに努力しないと経験できるところでもありません
だって出家したいと思う人っていうのは稀だからね
かなり挑戦的にやらないと
俗世間の考え方にどうせもう引っ張られますからね
だから涅槃という境地を体験するためにも
かなり引っ張っていかないといけないので
かなり精進しないと そういうことだから
仏教の世界は何言うのかというと
繊細はすべての生命やら生き方っていうのは
精進すること 努力することを励むこと
頑張ること 踏ん張ることによって成り立っているんだと
もうしょうがないんでしょうに
だから怠けっていうのはありえないんです
もし人が怠けるんだったら
これが異常で 精神的な病気です
まあ鳥インフルエンザみたいなもんなんですよ
もっとひどいんですけど
なのに人間は怠けたい
怠けたいとかね 怠けるためにあらゆる理由
訳を探してるんです 自己ベストを尽くすということは
仏教の世界では当たり前の話なんです
自己ベストを尽くすっていうのは
言うまでもないんだと
当たり前やと 当たり前やと思ってるんだから
自己ベストを尽くさない人々っていうのは
仏教ではすごく恩師力を見ていないんです
で まあそういうところでまあひと段落になりましたと思います
それから自己ベストについて
あと５分休憩の後で始めます
はい